Imagine you have a child and
they're playing soccer and uh,
your child is a pretty good soccer player.
No,
I'll tell you a different story.
This actually happened.
So I'm going to tell you a story about
hockey and I'm since I'm Canadian.
What the hell?
I might as well tell you
a story about hockey.
Um,
my son played hockey,
he still plays hockey.
He's a pretty good hockey player.
And my wife and I used to
go watch him play hockey.
There was an arena just down the
street from us and there was a nice
neighborhood league there.
And so they'd start the kids into teams
and then they'd let them play a few demo
games.
And if any team was getting stomped flat
or any other team was winning too much,
then they'd rebalanced the team so that
they were approximately equal in skill.
And so that was the sorting of the teams.
So,
um,
and then they,
then they were on their
teams and then they play,
you know,
15 games during the regular season.
They didn't have a little
tournament to see who won.
And,
uh,
it was really good.
It was good friendly league
and so my son's team was in,
I think it was the championship
game if I remember correctly.
And there's one kid on his team
who is the best player on the team,
but by quite a margin,
you know,
he was very fast on his feet.
He could,
he could skate rings
around a lot of the kids.
He was good at stick handling.
He was a good hockey player.
But um,
he had some problems.
This kid,
one problem was he wouldn't pass the puck.
Now you think,
well,
why the hell should you pass the puck
if you're the best hockey player?
Which is pretty much what he thought.
And the answer is,
well,
you're part of the team,
right?
You want to be the best
person on the team,
fair enough.
And you want to win the hockey game.
But you also want to what?
Make your team mates better players.
How's that?
Maybe you even want to meet
the people on other teams,
better players.
I knew now I know that's
going a little bit too far,
but you certainly want to make your
teammates better players and you might
think,
well,
why would you do that?
Because if they're better than
maybe you won't be the best.
While that's a boneheaded way of looking
at the world because first of all,
if you amp up the competition around you,
maybe that will motivate you
to eat to be even better.
And it's a hell of a way to win
by making everyone else lose.
That's not much of a victory.
And so if you have any sense,
you pass the damn puck,
even if you're the better player,
especially you especially do that.
Let's say you've got a
comfortable two goal lead,
well then maybe you can risk taking the
time away from that specific game to
build up the confidence,
confidence,
and ability of your team mates.
And then maybe everybody thinks that
you're a bit of a leader and they make you
team captain.
Not even so much because
you're the best hockey player,
but because,
well,
because why?
That's the question.
Okay.
So we're watching the game and it's pretty
exciting and it's real close game and
it's like three to three and it's a
minute left and another team zips down.
The nice and scores are
really brilliant goal.
And so my son's team loses except that
they were in the championship and it was
a really good game.
So you know whether or not they
lost is not all that obvious.
They lost that game.
But you know,
there's the broader context
to take into consideration.
Okay,
so this kid,
this this,
the star goes off the ice and he takes
his hockey stick and he smashes it on to
the cement and he's all angry
because as far as he was concerned,
he was robbed.
And maybe that's because of is useless.
Team mates who he didn't really
spend any time helping by the way.
And maybe it's because the referees were
unfair and who the hell knows why but
it wasn't fair and his idiot
farther rushes over to them
and consoles and and on
his loss and supports him in
his notion that he was robbed.
And I thought you
unspeakable son of a bitch
because he was an arrogant narcissist
and it was way more important to him that
he had a son who was a star then,
that he had a son who is a good person.
And that's absolutely inexcusable.
He made the wrong choice.
He sacrificed his son's soul in part to
help him save face for a hockey game.
That's not acceptable.
Okay?
So here's what you tell your children.
It doesn't matter whether you win or lose,
it matters how you play the game.
And so that's what the father should have
told the son and he should have meant
it.
And even better,
he should have known what it meant.
But who knows what that means because
you tell your children that and maybe
they're not so happy because they lost
the game and they look at you like you're
an alien.
And they think,
well,
what the hell do you mean by that?
Because obviously it matters whether you
win and it does matter whether you win.
So what is it that you mean when
you say that and your kid asks,
well what do you mean by that?
And you go,
well,
I don't know what it means,
but it's a good rule.
So what do you mean by that?
Here's what you mean.
And it relates to rule five,
which is don't make your,
don't let your children do anything that
makes you dislike them because other
people will dislike them then.
And you don't want other people to
dislike your children unless you want your
children to inhabit a world
where everyone dislikes them.
And maybe you do because
you don't like children.
And maybe you don't like your children
because you let them behave in ways that
makes you not like them.
And so the way you take revenge is by
not correcting them so that other people
will punish them because you don't
have the courage to discipline them.
And if you think that
people don't play that game,
then you don't know much about people
because they play that game all the time.